in this video we are going to showcase
to you guys quite a few transformers
that are massive in size
these gigantic robots were very rare and
some weren't even seen in movies but yes
they do exist and in a transformers
universe most of these characters even
though they are bigger than humans they
are still small in comparison to other
monsters especially the kaiju from toho
and legendary pitchers
but there are some which are totally
titanic and so in this video we will
show you all 10 transformers bigger than
godzilla himself so let's get down with
the sickness
number 10 majin zarak majin zark is a
ruthless killing mechanical creature who
is dreaded by the maximals the predacons
and anybody else who comes into contact
with him he has no sympathy no sorrow
and he kills all that is breathing majin
zarak's origins are unknown he was made
hundreds of years ago and advantage
without a trace in essence he is a bad
guy and was very large in size with
estimates putting him around 200 meters
or 656 feet tall around 250 feet taller
than godzilla which was around 400 feet
tall
number 9 triptycon triptycon was the
first intelligent decepticon city to
emerge in any continuity despite the
fact that there have been other sentient
decepticon cities before between those
continuities however his intelligence
and personality shifts from near
animalistic to an assassin with
aspirations for decepticon leadership
triptycon scale is similarly variable
and is always shown to be quite huge in
scale with a version of him being 278
meters or 912 feet tall tripticon was
also megatron's orbital base and
transforms into a nemesis class
battleship
number 8 broadside broadside is an
autobot triple changer who premiered in
1986. despite his robot mode broadside
also transforms into a jet fighter and
an aircraft carrier broadside is the
most out of scale transformer of all
time he moves into an aircraft ship that
can be very small in size
and sometimes into an unconvincingly
huge jet fighter well for one of his
variations he was at least 365 meters or
1200 feet tall and at times he's just a
little bit bigger than grimlock but in
his bigger scale he is three times
taller than legendary godzilla
number seven metroplex metroplex is a
gigantic autobot whose alternate mode is
a city he is gigantic and possesses a
more than capable arsenal of weaponry in
the autobot ranks metroplex doesn't care
for his own safety and is more than
willing to sacrifice anything if it
means securing the victory of his
comrades in war according to a japanese
comics the bomb article metroplex is 800
meters tall but in the marvel uk
transformers comics however it says that
he is only 700 feet tall so take your
pick
number six metro titan metro titan is a
huge warrior with a powerful freeze beam
that can stop most adversaries skull in
their tracks
built by the autobots on saturn's moon
titan metal titan however defected to
the decepticons and was stopped the ways
of evil by the nine great demon generals
which was bad news for the autobots
metro titan transforms from a large
robot into a multi-level city this mode
includes a surface bay with launch
mechanisms a helipad and parking for
several vehicles
metro titan would be in the same size
range as metaplex around 800 meters tall
number 5 omega supreme omegatron supreme
or just omega supreme is one of the
largest of the autobots he isn't one for
words preferring to let his gigantic
frame and similarly massive weapons to
speak for itself omega is the autobot's
last line of defense a titanic guardian
robot capable of striking terror and
panic in any decepticon who dares to
face him on the battlefield
even though he is very formidable in
battle he moves very slow but he does
cover his flaws with homing missiles it
can charge any target some estimates put
him at 805 meters or
2641 feet tall which alongside metro
titan and metroplex would be somewhere
in the same size range would be around 6
times the size of godzilla
number 4 the subtigar the so-called
decepticon is a hideous colossal beast
produced from the combined bodies of
hundreds of decepticons and uncountable
sweeps it is an extension of devoid's
will by manipulating a mysterious energy
found naturally on cybertron the devoid
forced the legions of warriors to
combine with the end result being the
monstrosity known as the decepticon
megatron and starscream personality has
kept them from joining with the merger
this massive robot would be anywhere
between 1 000 to 1 500 meters tall
number 3 fortress maximus fortress
maximus is another of the autobot's
largest robots he has the shape of a
large structure and can transform into a
massive robot ahead of time photos
maximus once met scorpenoc in the
transformers g1 carton series and beat
him with a couple of punches
despite his great power size and rank
fortress maximus is a weary and
reluctant warrior he tries to keep it to
himself most of the time but photos
maximus was at least 3 thousand meters
tall or ten thousand feet tall he would
be around 25 godzilla stacked one on top
of another
number two primus primus is the
benevolent god-like entity in the
fictional transformers comic universe
who fought against the chaos bring a
unicron
the lord of the light primus is the
being who created the transformers to
help him defeat unicron primus is the
twin brother of unicron his eternal foe
whom he battled for eons before going
into stasis primers also created the 13
the first primes to defeat his evil twin
brother and gas unicorn into deep space
he is of planetary size around the size
of jupiter
and number one unicron unicron is prime
minister's twin brother eternal arch
enemy he is known as the dark god the
destroyer the chaos bringer and the
planet eater he is on a mission to
consume the entire universe his goal is
to find tranquility before
being the center of a swirling limitless
river of nothingness at the end of all
things putting an end to the borders
from creation boasting independence
around him he is also of planetary size
around the size of jupiter unlike bay
farmers unicron where he's just the size
of earth
and so with that we come to the end of
the video on the 10 transformers that
are bigger than godzilla so if you like
our pick then do leave a thumbs up and
also don't forget to subscribe to be a
part of our minecube family also smash
that bell button for regular updates on
new monster videos
right here on this channel till the next
one take care fam